you guys this is sports without balls
thank you so much for coming out tonight
just clap oh it's like we're in an arena
wow this is this is going to be the best
podcast this room has ever [ __ ] seen
let me tell you that much thank you guys
so much a huge round of applause to the
LA a podcast festival in particular
Graham Elwood Chris man CD Dave Anthony
and Andy wood for putting it on for
years in a row Kris just told me this is
the first time a sports podcast has been
let in the Bobcats festival maybe
perhaps it's not a very popular genre as
we're learning tonight but I listen you
got to start somewhere right fans okay
fantastic a quick shout out to
audible.com it offers a listeners a free
audiobook of your choice free 30-day
trial membership audible.com backslash
LA pod fest and you get to choose over
180,000 audio programs and he get a free
book yes good job good job audible all
right here we go you guys very excited
break up our first guest he hails from
Chicago huge sports fan he's on the
Goldbergs he was on Curb Your Enthusiasm
many other shows that that were on air
please welcome my friend Jeff Garlin
sit next to me and our final guest fan
favorite she is co-hosted numerous of
these shows with me she tours the
country doing stand-up a country cool
please welcome Trish Suhr hey I'm in the
middle next there and yeah so you called
are you returning my call oh all right
I'll talk to you later nothing important
all right no why okay please tell her I
said hi hi Jeff Garlin already doing a
phone bit you guys ah but I have to buy
some reason I have a cell phone is
because my wife wants me to have it so
she can let me know when she's
disappointed in any time day or night
and it works I Jeff I I know you have a
lot of things going on so I just I just
wanted to say thank you for being here I
know it's not a huge crowd but there's
at least eight hundred sixty people
somewhere in whatever this is a podcast
so however many people are here is
wonderful that's that's why I'm right
here at appeal so you know I didn't know
about this podcast they're not getting
the word out to people who don't care
about podcasts so it's not like there's
like oh we come to this thing they
didn't publicize it good enough okay
when the Emmys had nothing to do with it
did cuz mom gives a [ __ ] examine damn
now be honest that no one cares about
the Emmys well I think too many people
care about end of too many of them and
they all suck I hope to one day cater
them you go the way if you had a company
that catered the Emmys there be some big
bucks coming your way yeah I hope to
cater him I don't want to be a server
but by god I hope that I've got a
catering company that I've invested in
that's worked its way up to catering the
Emmys all right that's my worst
nightmare ever going back
to like restaurant I think I would you
call it post-traumatic away during
disorder that's something shivers when
you're like hey what do you want then
you just don't sleep for a week are you
guys sports there's so many this is a
wonderful time to be alive and be a
sports fan I there's there's so many
things happening I'm trying to remain
positive because I'm in New York Giants
fan and just a quick stat this is out of
order we're going to do baseball first
but this stat grabbed my attention today
the New York Giants is the first team in
NFL history to lose the first two games
of a season despite leading by 10 points
or more in the fourth quarter yeah yeah
yeah Wow yeah so you're owing to it's
almost as bad as I'm assuming you're a
Bears fan yes I am Oh into ya Trisha's
accent is actually for real and say 'no
no kentucky kentucky yeah yep now
married to a Cleveland Browns fan yeah
apologies all right thank ya accept our
condolences I'm gonna start with the
story I'm going to start with a fantasy
baseball story listen right off the bat
I'm having a good time I'm having a
wonderful day today because I've Jeff
and Trish know the news and my sister is
put up with us for 180 games knows the
news my fantasy baseball team the
Rockford peaches are in the finals we're
in the finals this is a ragtag bunch if
I told you the lineup you'd be like who
and I this is my first year playing
fantasy I'm the only woman and it was
hard on all of us it was listening it
was a team beyond a team effort ah but I
want to tell you the story because it
directly involves Jeff Garlin we had
lunch like a month ago and I was telling
him the story of my fantasy baseball
team and I've told the story in podcast
before but no one to a live audience as
many as yourselves and I and so this was
in a nutshell I've printed out the
emails i'll just read you a couple of
the email exchanges i drafted in my last
pick noah syndergaard a fantastic
pitcher for the Mets no one knew him
before the season started have like a
Mets connection anyway they call him
Thor he's doing really well
and about a month in he gets called up
to the major leagues and I'm also he
wasn't on my roster i didn't knew what
had i didn't know what happened so I
emailed the Commissioner of the league
and I said hey I drafted syndergaard do
you know what happened this other team
AKA phil has syndergaard so it went
through an exchange of emails between a
fill myself and the commissioner where
the Commissioner apologized to this guy
Phil and said listen Noah syndergaard is
Aaron Foley's player and I just want to
read you the exchange now this is a this
is a this is a dude who I think might
have too much time on his hands I want
you to I'll just read you this is the
reply hi Phil Commissioner of the league
I screwed up totally my fault you have
syndergaard it's aaron Foley's a player
would you please a relinquishment Agard
and just know that you got him for free
for the last couple weeks this is how it
replies well this is interesting I'm
looking at the transactions and I see he
was added to Rockford peaches roster on
318 and removed from an ad drop later
that evening by the LM league manager
but what happened between 318 and he was
dropped in 57 when i added him what
happened that seven weeks he sat as a
free agent shouldn't this had been
addressed then and not after he's been
on my roster for three weeks and started
four games from me I wouldn't under I
would understand if it was a few days
after the mistake / error or something
but it's kind of crazy to request this
now sorry if I sound nuts because you
are but just weird getting a request to
give up a player after he's been on my
roster for three weeks back and forth
back and forth back and forth and so I
was like all right I have to I have to
just get some perspective here so I
emailed them hey guys thanks for
reaching out on behalf Phil clearly this
is an awkward situation but one that can
be easily remedied this is my first year
playing fantasy so I just assumed
syndergaard would be on my roster when
he got called up now I know it was just
an accidental or clerical error that he
wasn't listed on my team the entire time
as you can see from the emails I did
immediately reach out to the
commissioner when he was called up the
East is imploding and Isis will probably
hold sign ups at the beverly center soon
so clearly this issues is not a high
priority that being said if you're not
going to release him just let me know so
i can adjust my roster accordingly
continued success to both of you the
seat season as long as you're not
playing me sincerely Rockford peaches
now this is the last email before Jeff
Garlin gets involved Phil yes I would
say this is very awkward but you guys
can do whatever you think is right I
wasn't sure if you two were serious or
joking because this is the first time
I've ever come across this in fantasy
sports where I have been asked to give
up a player after owning him for four
weeks and honestly I don't want to give
him up because he's twenty percent of my
pitching rotation so when I picked up
off the free agent list where he SAT for
seven weeks could have used that roster
spot a month ago to pick someone else up
that could have helped me all year I'm
the one who committed no errors in this
situation yet i'll be the most penalized
but since it seems to me a serious
request i'll leave it up to the
commissioner to make a decision on the
matter I told both of them to go [ __ ]
themselves and keep syndergaard arm
that's how I ended it and then I had
lunch with mr. Jeff Garlett and I told
them the story and I sent all the emails
to Jeff Garlin I go home later that day
and there is an email from dress to fill
and the Commissioner of the league that
says I fill this is jeff garlin who are
you and what do you do for a living I
need to know in return i'll answer i'll
answer anything you ask me all my best
joke of which i had a breakdown i had a
little breakdown I thought it was the
greatest thing I'd ever seen / now I'm
gonna be fired from my personally
attempted playing fantasy baseball I
kept getting emails how does Jeff Garlin
know re mess haha
and I had to come up with some sort of
like oh I was just joking around and I
sent him one thing and then all of a
sudden he was just joking around and
thankfully they all found it funny and I
wasn't fired um so Jeff you don't know
this but here's the the final email came
in today at 329 p.m. I somehow pulled it
off and I'm in the finals against Phil I
will read you Phil's roster in a little
bit and you're like it's every every
slot is an all-star hey Erin congrats on
making the finals last year with two
extra teams it was for eight hundred
dollars for first and three hundred
seventy dollars per second meanwhile I
didn't even know I was getting paid
because I'm never getting paid not sure
what the new payout is with the new two
teams but i think it's higher with it
being a daily league and a lot of work
so much somewhat are wondering if you
want to split the pot a little too
guaranteed a little bit more money for
each of us I was thinking 670 and the
title and the trophy for first and 500
for the second that's the old payout if
you're interested we can figure out how
the commissioners bring up the new money
but if you want to play it out as it has
been that's cool too just thought i'd
send an email the blood seconds he's
scared what do you think jeff i find
none of this interesting it's like
telling somebody about your dreams I
just was angry at the way you were being
treated and they were further airy me
emails between fell and I that's didn't
want to reveal too much about himself to
me and I said suit yourself Phil there's
lots to learn about me
yeah i'm i buy the story riveting here's
the beauty of sports you could win is it
was at one week against him or is it
like you know cuz you play and had dad
yeah and i play in rotisserie so it is
yours like the final week this coming
week i have to double check but i think
it's this week and that's it so yeah
arguably anybody know anything could
happen that could happen it sounds great
i'm excited for you but but these you
should Russell is Russell Martin Adrian
Gonzalez Matt Carpenter Kris Bryant
Desmond Kinsler Rizzo trout Bryce Harper
here Irene I mean Rizzo trout Harper
tell me Bryant that's just a big bowl of
wrong I have two of those players and I
have a bryant and i have harper and
they're on fire and bryant is even
motivated i don't even know what our
personal is his team fell apart so it's
very very exciting that oh yeah it's a
no first of all who cares except i do i
think i think i care about you I don't
want they rely more know oh yeah of
course relax but I want you to send fell
an email and in the email just go look I
know we're in the middle of playing Jeff
Garlin big deals but we should split the
money this way and agree to it in
advance if you when you get three
dollars and I get the whole pop if if I
win I get the whole pot but you get the
rights to send a guard for the next two
seasons yeah Garlin wants to know how
you feel about this and what you're
wearing that's someone yeah well I'm
gonna write all that down it i'm going
to send it to him if you're not like an
insane baseball fan basically and you're
right anything could happen so I feel
first of all I feel good about
everything but it would be like his team
is like Iron Man Captain America and the
Hulk and by team is like Colonel Mustard
professor plum and mrs. pika but but
come on a monster at one point did it
I think there's a chance right Megan
served by the way that's the thing it's
one week how do you know first up Adrian
Gonzalez talk about Baron Vaughn and
consistency so I don't know what I mean
hey I'm a huge Dodger fan you are you
died your plan I like University
Kentucky baseball we don't we don't have
a team on the team your closest team is
the rain is the Reds right uh yeah
that's art will mean to the other call
uh you know what people in Ohio call
since an editor called since the ducky
oh yeah honey anything that's kind of
out in the woods fontucky if you want to
go out there don't ask your land what's
fun talking exactly Fontana it's where
the speedway is here in California but
they call it fontucky because they race
nascar there oh ok well anything we're
the butt of every joke the UH gift that
you didn't pee on it you're screwed you
are the Bluegrass State yeah and and you
should be proud it's a beautiful area
there's horses see you sound like a
tourist mirror I'm allergic to horses
but I I'm Pro Kentucky thank you driven
Kentucky many a time you had a great
basketball player Kentucky that he's 11
him Kyle Macy yes we did a play for the
Phoenix Suns yes he did but in general
Jon Stewart and I performed at in
Lexington at university Kentucky at the
wrap and yes at the rat they at the
right now not only we performed at Rupp
Arena we're under big theater was a big
theater wasn't Opera House the Kentucky
theatre why was it the call the context
I don't know what it was called point
thing is they went to a Kentucky
basketball game the next day is very
impressive thank you thank you for
loving on my state operation there's
lots of good things there I you know I
think that the one thing about Kentucky
that probably is true there's a lot of
stupid people but I probably I'm not
saying you know the accent throws at
that well sure but outside of the accent
I think brilliant I met no I met a lot
of people I'm not fond of Cincinnati but
I like we don't we don't
I'm them I debt so how should I know
it's over the river yeah oh ha through
the woods it's not so super conservative
retime I do a show there halfway through
the show I think to myself why am I here
constantly they are there they're yeah
they're Kentucky line yeah and the Reds
not doing good agents no good let's do
baseball state of the union wait so Jeff
explain your rotisserie League
rotisserie is that you pick a team full
of players you draft your snake draft or
you know first through 12 then 12 ends
up picking first in the second round you
go up and down and then at the end of
the season your team let's say whoever's
accumulated the most home runs I got you
they would get if there's 12 players
that would get 12 points and the least
home runs would be one point and you'd
have in between so you're going every
day on ER a strikeouts wins saves
something else and then the whip we had
one of my favorite walks and hits
burning pitched innings pitched and then
on the other side it's a runs home runs
RBIs uh on-base percentage no no no uh
steals uh just count that's one thing
their cups are my ladies let's go I like
you and early no you don't do so that's
good though because every like you have
a good week in my league and then it's
just a race but I by the way if you have
a good week you can play somebody who
has a better week yeah you know it's so
random yeah I don't like I do like had
to had in football but you know baseball
not fun but I've done it before I don't
like yeah what I do like is like you
know I did this fantasy league so I
could get to know the National League
more your size i'm doing a sports
podcast janelle only know it's bold I
just feel like I'm just being a Yankees
fan yeah you learn a lot about me learn
all the obscure player best hitters are
on detroit city tampa bay it doesn't
matter yeah i know i agree i've got like
two baseball fan it's pretty cool it is
pretty cool it is it's like the ultimate
like sort of board games
weigh in you're late you're way beyond
where you expected when you showed it to
me you were like eight out of ten I just
want my goal was to get halfway through
the path no see my goal for you is to
beat Phil [ __ ] you Phil yeah and then
I'll ride him ago what happened family a
lot of us went to Vegas and laid
everything out what's wrong with you
Phil oh my dear dear Phil I gotta say
beyond water yeah water just water so
what's all right so let's just save the
Union Cubs you must be I'm sorry about
today I they lost kicking the [ __ ] out
of the car and they have that but
doesn't matter the Cardinals or the
Pirates are going to win the the Cubs
are in the will be in the one game
wild-card playoff and they probably
could go that can go either way I you
know I look I'm a Cubs fan that they're
already way past what I thought they'd
be it's like it's like playing fell in
the championship I wrote down the ages
of your team is like it I think it's
gonna be so so like the oldest player
that's nuts he's 24 what is it Coughlin
is that a pronouncement oh by the way I
just got a call I mean I got an email
from Anthony Rizzo's charity which time
the time just did and they asked me to
do this year I can't do you want me to
recommend you yeah because the payment
for tom was first pitch yeah I know we
discussed that on the side it was your
the second man Wayne charity balls do
you've done I don't care always positive
just yeah I am always buzzer I said
always positive okay chef look at these
ages I'm saying listen I'm not blowing
such a pyramid first of all i love i
love Joe Maddon from Tampa Bay do you
know what I have I the Cubs made me and
this is true and I I went down to the
field when they played the Dodgers and I
show Joe I've got to know Georgia press
conference with him he's amazing i did a
pregame press conference with a bit
which was very fun wait so tell us about
that but I've I just sat in the dugout
they would ask questions a lot of times
he turned to me go what do you think and
I would answer that's also awesome it
was really cool but I got the Cubs made
a shirt because I made a joke when I
when I first met him he said to me he
kept on referencing he loves Curb Your
Enthusiasm he loves Larry so everything
was about Larry Larry this Lee and I'm
standing there meeting him it wasn't
like Oh Jeff so good to meet you let's
have poppy let's hang out it was you got
to bring Larry to a game that type of
stuff so I went up into the booth so do
the broadcast a little while later that
day and I made fun of myself and him
saying that nice and all I want to be
his Joe's best friend so that became
like a thing and the Cubs made me a
t-shirt with a picture that they took of
joe and i like talking in the dugout and
it says best friends oh my god it's the
only one that's made and they're making
one for Joe he is the reason that
they're great by the way great talent
don't get me wrong and certain guys
their blossoming all this stuff but a
lot of that has to do with the tone but
yeah you know if you see as a things as
do simple better yeah the reason why I
know Joe Maddon is because yeah my
parents are obsessive you know this but
my parents and Trish hears about it
every week but my parents and my sisters
in the crab tonight are obsessive tampa
bay rays fans but snow guys they might
get kicked out of the league what do you
mean oh there's a great chance that the
Florida Marlins and the Tampa Bay Rays
will be not be in baseball in the next
two or three years well I stadium issues
there's a lot to do with it but these
are two teams that I mean the Rays have
gone it's weird now the Rays other bad
well what I liked about the Rays all
these years is Joe Maddon and he would
take these people out there yeah I mean
they did like better than expected they
had like their entire pitching just went
to crawl like everyone was hurt but I
kind of fell in love with the rays and
Joe because of Joe Maddon does stadium
yeah it's that's a gorgeous hunk of duty
Wow anytime you can hit a pop up that
gets caught in
after like is that like how is that
legal like I don't I do I I have an
obsession at home by the way is
considered a marvel of modern technology
compared to well supposedly they're
trying to move the team to Tampa right
they've been trying to move it to Tampa
forever from st. Pete's but the problem
is no one lives in that area dying for
like seven months everyone's 85 no one
cares yeah except me i need a television
they do have except Mary and Dick Foley
intrinsic Foley I care I call my guy
they call me what do they live they live
in in the south of tampa bradenton area
and they've watched every game forever
the thing is they had to tampa pray to
the Red Sox so the Red Sox bring home no
Pittsburgh Pirates Mets no no but masses
points8 I really think they should be
pirate fans is much more enjoyable know
god I wish they were here my mother way
that's pretty much that of the new
stadiums the pirate stadium my baseball
feet field is the nicest one of them all
it's so nice yeah my mom calls about
over three days for different reasons
two reasons one to tell us what food has
been recalled that week and she saw
Jesus me soft cheese last week it was
cucumbers cucumbers we found out what
you want to know that's good information
you have Garland and then she calls me
about with Tampa Bay Rays stories I
constantly and she is a term now that
people that the die-hard listeners a
sports without balls now right in
Trisha's adopt it into her life and
that's when they don't like a player
they'd scream back on the bus on him us
they've had to go to Durham back to
durham they scream and that's what I
screamed at Preston Parker wide receiver
for the New York Giants all day today
back on the boss did he drop a lot of
bomb dropped 700 the first game in the
second game oh jeez but Beckham I saw
that one catch that was ridiculous just
throw to him every time every time who
are we fooling Rueben Randle takes seven
hour naps and it goes out for snacks
president Parker can't even if they
handed him the ball drop it and we'll do
that too ah i am a running back today
who fumbled this way off the starting
lineup it looks like where are you
playing fantasy football yeah honey hill
who's a running back for the bengals who
i drafted in the second round maybe
first ma'am him and matt forte remember
who i was at tail end yeah but anyhow
point thing is he fumbled a lot today so
he's not he's here back on the bus he's
better now truly he's rid of his bus
yeah Trish is playing fantasy football
she has no idea what she's doing
flippers I've never played my girlfriend
who lives in park city utah they're all
nutty nutty sports fans I'm like um
acute heart said he's known for the you
know sporting news every year declares
park city sports central ESPN it was
between Connecticut and park city the
[ __ ] you talking about to be fair she's
a former Olympian so this is a freely
let's be fair she's a former Olympian
season seemed like an easy task in Orion
they can move over the fact what kind of
which what she do swimming o chosen Utah
yeah she married an Olympic skier oh how
they get together differ different does
date blind a blind date no longer dating
site you're just a big tinder open I've
been home in a direction hockey swimming
scene so I got screwed I mean fantasy
football league she put me in an I've
zero idea what I'm doing I wait did you
draft we did not owe draft so I didn't
even know I came to read you just said
you did an audit she did not a driver
what is an auto draft in autograph means
when you can't be there you're the draft
that the computer will draft for you
what do you mean you can be there what
kind of dedication is the way i sat in
my goddamn bedroom for four weeks
the MLB draft I had spreadsheets I had
anxiety attacks I was sneaking red wine
up to the desk auto you are so beautiful
you are I'm just looking over at you're
now going my god she's so beautiful
sweat about draft I just love you you
think I'd be here if it wasn't for you
know I know I really I got people get
other white people people I'll take out
to lunch no you don't know I mean will
guide you so much more than you on right
now okay when you're with me you loser
did she good job people come out and go
how'd you get Jeff Garlin he's so hard
to get a hold of another lose my friend
that means grads popped on and by the
way I am hard to get a little hold up
because I want to be hard to get them
yeah cuz I don't want to get be gotten a
hold of don't get a hold of me I don't
want to be a whole social security is
fine let go 710 but i'll do anything
with with you for you and it's not even
a favor it's just joyous to be next oh
wait are you wait trish regan sweet we
gotta help Trish with her so this auto
draft is bunch she named it say of Tom
Brady why you got a good team hold on a
singing at Tom Brady's recorder back yet
31 points not cheering for team I was
between the last two they owe a Antoine
Brown Pittsburgh what the [ __ ] Johnson
on Detroit I got an opacity Lamar Miller
on Miami he's doing pretty good Alfred
Morris over great no he's not but he's
doing he's good Raja Graham one of the
best tight ends in football Edelman
Edelman's but ailments like her
my boy he's sitting right boys sitting
here so scam Newton Bernard will be the
new starting running back in Cincinnati
ISM next week which will [ __ ] me and
it's great that today for your game you
had your kicker on the bench fantastic
10 that's Mason Crosby do at eight point
three seven points today and your
defense but what st. Louis have got four
points there you go damn ride oh I
thought st. Louis ado don't know how to
drive I accidentally dropped a kicker
today they didn't know I mean to do that
our channel so that's what you had a
kicker in there and I've done the idea
that you had two kickers is just
beautiful like a wasn't easy friends too
defensive team of two kickers believe
the idea that just is so illogical let
me have a backup kicker in case
something happens they're so hard to
pick up on the waiver wire if I could
only get six points in next week's
matchup so stupid i don't know i'm doing
i do don't know what you're doing but
you're gonna do a you have a good team
really do well thank god cuz it what
were your auto advice let me just give
her one piece of advice thank you Jim
start off your players each and every
week don't that levy them all on the
bench that's all I do that if you're
listening in erie young fantasy football
baseball player the bench is not a good
school make sure all your starting
positions are filled that's all other
than that I know nothing oh yeah don't
have extra kickers I don't even
everybody knew I'd an app should have
called me and save an app for that I
don't I don't do fantasy I bet [ __ ] to
do I fear busy I'm information
nexus dog so yeah it's tough I've got
two dogs they do they do I can't work at
home because of my dogs same on the same
care because they they're up back and
forth I want to go out I want to come in
[ __ ] you yes the truth is I listen to
them and I give them attention all day
and I get nothing done for my children
they're off at school learning making
the world a better place how old are
your kids 42 and though they're 19 and
15 did I play sports no they do not they
both used to when they were younger but
they do not play the skateboard that's
sort of a sport it is a sport x games
you know sure but they know they love
skateboarding and yeah I want my older
one boxes laxing yeah professionally
really no but he does go to the gym and
box almost every day with the gym how do
we uh ball love how do we yes it don't
happen between we are in love we are in
love we just got somebody I married your
gay bingo jingo she's not gonna work
bingo it works great for friendship [ __ ]
is it fantastic but if you and I and we
are in love we love each other madly but
unfortunately they'll be no you no
touching it's just wrong on my end wrong
on your end well yeah yeah its role for
me this ends would be fortunately
they'll be no touching yes because I
like you know boobs yeah by the way I
can make a joke right here are you don't
say it no no no but I you I I at one
point I probably had some right ok but
only more importantly how do i meet
Rhonda Rousey through Jeff Garlin how do
you meet I think you're your boy that
boxes are we should hang out and go
stalk Ronda Rousey boxes at a gym in
Glendale yeah I have the address and I'm
thinking about doing some flybys
whoa we could do a remote like just like
screws by like i can say i'm filming
something and get permission to go in
there and talk to her and you could come
with me and things because what you just
said but but isn't she not gay no I just
want to hang out here she not gay yeah
should not go super-stretch she's super
straight yeah you see so does this thing
is super straight aspect ratio homophobe
because that's super straight okay
that's when you're so straight no
[ __ ] way is any one of the gay world
coming anywhere near me I am super
straight to this regular straight people
are comfortable but if you're super
straight that means you hate gays I
think after like if we gave Rhonda like
for gin and tonics axe astrix scroll dog
something might happen can I give you
the honest opinion yes have a slumber
party with her yo [ __ ] you will why
wouldn't you women women are so soft to
the touch i understand i don't get
heterosexual women i've still never
figured it out you know homosexual women
really make sense to me heterosexual
that makes no sense you like penises
that makes no that's just me I number
party with Rashid arises she's so bad
like my only goal for 2016's have a
slumber party with Robin Arryn you
haven't you haven't booked a lot of gigs
well because I've been focusing on
organizing a slumber party with Ronda
Rousey but do not think that wouldn't
get attention make your whole twitter
site about having a slumber party with
Ronda Rousey party with Ronda Rousey
what a tool I tried a written letter
well done day three I thought it best I
stop talking like an old woman Dave for
did another flyby from for Glendale
I've still haven't lost the old woman
voice cuz if you called errands and
heidrun to come have a flutter parted
she thinks she's coming to hang out with
an old lady dearest Rhonda Erin against
my dearest dearest run I've got three
new sleeping bags for us longer do you
want to know the truth and I swear I'm
going to give these odds the odds are
much higher of you sleeping with her
than me okay I'm including if I'm
divorced uh she got plenty of her own
money she doesn't need money yeah
there's nothing I could offer her except
just you know the kindness kindness and
I don't know if she gets enough of that
the humanity ya know world that she
lives in you know who knows but here's
what I do now I don't know actually I
don't know anything so that's a thing I
don't know [ __ ] if you would have asked
me would I be doing a ladies-only
podcast at a podcast festival and the
mum my first of i stayed in this hotel
for like three months once it was
filming a pilot for Fox called barclays
people never aired I was a series and
soul series never aired we just got the
footage hit play by the way I actually
might acquire the footage for a special
just to show clips of me and also come
with commentary I think it might be fun
that could be fun alright but anyhow the
point being is I was staying here and
years in the future they'll be these
show called podcasts so my my mom called
with a Carlos Pena story uh and she said
who doesn't love a good Carlos Pena
story probably okay at least 10 to 12
people uh Mary Foley called me she said
Aaron I've got a story for your sports
pod whatever see he's retired he just
retired it's a charming story just okay
he's played for the Cubs wait for the
Cubs play for Tampa Bay but it was it
was a feel good story she was getting
choked up as she was told it I was of
course crying because everything in
sports makes me weep uh he said we they
were he's being interviewed he's like
they're like oh you're so positive you
were such a great teammate you always so
positive so positive he's like it's
because of my father growing up
couldn't hit the ball and my father was
always so positive and so encouraging he
never said a bad word I would always be
like foul ball after foul ball and my
father would be like yes but the foul
balls are going so far sweetest thing
ever that is a great sports are gonna be
mighty honest good that's one thing you
don't hear stuff like that usually years
what the [ __ ] son you're ruining our
relationship but you'll be a pro someday
yeah isn't that the same no love for me
but your foul balls are going so far and
you hit him so well and I mean and these
are the ones that were going back behind
it he smashed through our cars three
times so those foul balls but I thought
that was the sweetest anyway so put that
in your sports pod whatever quote the
Mary Foley and soft cheese stay away
from soft cheese um if the baseball
season ended today who are we picking
what our thoughts Trish fishing in terms
of what who are we picking in terms of
what though it is if it's season ended
today what do you thinks gonna happen
picking that sounds I think that sounds
like you know nothing of sports you mean
who's going to the World Series final
four but I know more than baseball
league Super Bowl how would you feel
like you're pregnant get how did she
become your car shows nothing she knows
she knows a lot about nothing I'm not
she knows a lot about the Seahawks a lot
of you want to see what's going on in
that game and then I'll tell you my
right what happened here what I'm saying
is this if the season ended today you
know we've got probably Cubs pirates in
it in a playoff we've got Mets Dodgers
okay Cardinal nuts here go effing nuts
she's going first though go frustration
I'm having Wi-Fi difficulty go ahead
okay Jeff hits it I say the Cubs beat
the Pirates in the one-game playoff I
say the Dodgers beat the Cardinals in
the other thing and then the Cubs beat
thee who would they play mats mats Cubs
beat them that's easy and then the Cubs
will play the Dodgers and the Dodgers
will beat the Cubs hmm the Dodgers will
play in the World Series against Gladys
Knight and the pips
I know my American League one's a little
bit off but follow me here all right so
the Yankees and the Blue Jays make it
yes okay the Royals make it yeah yep and
the Texas Rangers make yep okay all of
those teams go to a Gladys Knight
concert and they refuse to play because
Gladys Knight told the story of not
being allowed to play Little League
baseball and they said [ __ ] it and the
pips hips the pip said they'll cover
everything out there turns out she's got
a great curveball baby they beat the
dodgers because all the American League
teams teams are filled with gentlemen so
they beat the dodgers who are [ __ ]
they hate women yeah they a black
menacing background everything that the
last night the pimps represent the
Dodgers [ __ ] hate and it's a tough
series but Gladys Knight wins when she
wins she goes to New York and she looks
up your friend Phil they make out and
have a baby who turns out to be a monkey
because phil has a weird gene inside his
sperm that monkey grows up to be an
ambidextrous pitcher no watchmaker and
he works out watches and he becomes very
well known in the watch world and that's
part of baseball history wow this day
dr. history that is that's what it's
telling me right now uh cousin to do the
thing that's what i got for Jeff well
not a logical score I mean like what
wasn't that logical what I just totally
was right it's a you know why babes the
pits were known for their harmony and
artful glove work glove work and they
also knew how to do a good shift yes so
I'm telling you I hate the shift i hate
the shift a hypership I may I love it I
wish the whole team would ship listen
whatever I want to do I want to see a
bat all right I'm the matter
hold on I'm manager the Dodgers if I
hate the team we're playing and we're
beating the [ __ ] out of them and I have
a great picture going ok I would take my
entire team and put him down the first
base line and say yeah let's see let's
see if you can hit yeah I don't think
you can hit our picture and the batter
will be so freaked out they'll strike
out I what I think it over is you know
you're a baseball player if you don't
know what the shift is is if like eighty
percent of the time you're always hit a
ball through the first and second base
they'll take the shortstop and put them
between first and second base so you're
just basically eft and they do this
every single time and if you're a
batterer I don't understand why you
don't practice every single day with the
pips as your backup to hit the ball to
the goddamned left side of the infield
let's side of the infield every day is
that you and your husband yeah you
actually use a picture of you and your
husband your thing as my screensaver
married for five years that's why it's
weird I love my wife but she's not going
on my screen soon all my ex-girlfriends
on my screen saver yeah I have all her
ex girlfriend they're just sitting there
hanging out having no idea i look at
them when I've not worked for a while I
combine hola Claire salad my favorite I
here's what I don't want sorry Erin up
here I don't want a Cardinals Blue Jays
World Series I don't want to i love all
birds it's all good it will kit will
kill me I don't want the Texas Rangers
in that I want to loon Jays you see I
don't my dolls are you're waiting for
the Mets I'll give you Yankees Mets
Houston Royals why do my chores because
they're not gonna be here they're the
big story this year I'm cheering for the
Astros cuz whoo cheers for them by the
way i agree with you i'd love to see the
Astros play the White Sox all that
happened and the Astros lost by the way
I made
I made a horrible prediction to Tom
Pappas uh granddaughter oh no not yet
another 10 years uh that the White Sox
would play the Washington Nationals in
the ball series this year I was a little
off oh god oh oh I know what happened
what happened the Yankees are up 11 to
20 tell you about my am i oh you know I
access one out what's his name is on my
team the pitch my mats Harvey yeah and
they took him out after like five
innings in the yield like shut out the
Yankees they take him out there then
zoom we talked about the excitement that
Romo's out I'm sorry she wanted to talk
some football I'll talk sexual Romo's on
my fantasy league team I'm gonna have to
pick up that schmuck on the niners uh
tony romo broke his collarbone sport
officials shake figured he went back for
a snap decided he wanted a fish and
something went horribly wrong uh I don't
like injuries I don't anything is I hate
the Cowboys with everything I'm made of
but I don't cheer for people being it
like I was like oh yeah like eagles fan
like the Eagles fans are chu who will
cheer any opposing player getting it
you're kind of it remembers this but
last year the Eagles fans arguably I
think are the worst all right they stole
someone's prosthetic leg after last year
they stole someone's prosthetic leg you
know what was it was a woman was a woman
stole someone's prosthetic leg after a
game the guy was like so we could give
me my leg back and you're like I mean
they had a jail in there in there the
Eagles but anyway dez bryant out with a
foot injury take it I'll take it Romo
with the collarbone I feel horrible not
really you don't after last week I don't
want to win because your team is in on
crutches and with I patches and no hair
matter know what that mean but he is not
a super bowl-winning quarterback so it's
not like we're taking him out of
something he's just not i think i think
the steelers are going to join
I hate this dealership true sorry Tyler
Lockett on uh oh I'm sorry Trish did you
see this story last week that the Browns
this is before Menzel did fairly well
today I know he had I mean that was just
shocking poor Mariota I hear that's a
welcome to them welcome to the exact
hashtag fail for cartel what that's that
what they wanted to like blow the season
so they can maybe get Cardale Jones from
our state university yeah that's that's
that's it like before the season starts
there like a hashtag fail for we're
looking at we're looking at the Seahawks
sports awesome as a serious look at us
yes it might be a picture of food uh oh
yeah your text what I got a picture of
food you was no one was amused I was
sitting here reading your text very
exciting all right let's talk about some
highlights of the NFL ever to get you
people back on track ah cowboy is any
all right how about the Eagles how about
the excitement I have that they're
[ __ ] the bed every 20 seconds early
they look horrible oh I'm loving it
everything should get tape out honey
I've taped the game and I rewatched it I
didn't Manziel sober throwing the ball
to someone that catches it right for
Cleveland headline someone someone
sneezed and Cutler's hammy blew out yes
I sneezed watching the game here in
California it affected him Jay Jay
Cutler can we just could we just talk
Cutler know arguably no one of the most
glorious arms I've ever seen I love his
throwing arm he's a douche
all right here's what it is you know
what there really is I'm tell you cuz
he's dating that 10 not David they're
married they're on their side kid but
there were by eldren no one's taking
this I have the answer to jay cutler
okay no one has it I have it Jay Cutler
is a diabetic I am also a diabetic I'm a
type 2 diabetic he is a type one diet
when you're of diabetes your mood can
swing like the wind okay jay cutler his
moods and is off being off sometimes
good so I was bad has everything to do
with his blood sugar levels at any given
moment give him a [ __ ] River Gemma
not you personally your sneakers make
you feel better he just put a Snickers
oh that's my theory on why he's so happy
sometimes sometimes it's a look on his
face yeah it's like the road call that
resting aggravation ugly resting things
we're starting to get that it gets
meaning it's all I don't know but but
you know Jay Cutler has like a doofus
space last thing doofus he does and so I
just did it that's why people chuckled
if you're listening at home this picture
well picture my face like Jay Cutler's
now all right now picture me wearing an
Abe Lincoln cosmic walking hand in hand
into the Emmys with Jay Cutler in full
barian food that isn't it is an
interesting theory it is it really a
very but is the case I'm like I'm in
select wouldn't you have him on some
kind of like museum built into his like
he's got a pump the minute notice he
does so the point I'm making is we're
talking about a disease there is no
logic to a disease this is the reason it
will come out after his careers over
that's what he'll talk about it might
even be a broadcaster people love him
and go why are you so nice you know the
media trust 34-30 behind the diabetes
all that be so good if this is true that
would make a great 30
excellent yeah yeah saying you have to
do the commentary cuz you the life I
don't know I'm good no one can contact
me so I don't want to do that I don't
want to give it really that that the yes
I huge swings yeah but I was about to
say the only cubs and bears like
documentaries I've been asked but I've
done too yeah and I don't do them
anymore why what happened oh god we're
getting a live sports reactions during a
bog rest behind so remember when they
threw the ball what the f have your no
warning i like i like to chill out maybe
win the Super Bowl I'll never forgive
I'll never forgive them for throwing
that ball I was on a gay cruise in my
cabin anybody angry so angry let me tell
you something about a gay cruise I
shared a castle on this night it was the
greatest week of my life it is if you're
in your cabin there's something wrong
with you you need to be out there
dancing at a white party having a good
time not during the super bowl with
2,600 gay men they could give a [ __ ]
about the game committee with a story no
they would walk by and scream out that's
a nice outfit and I had to take myself
and my sports problem into my cabin
otherwise i was on the dance floor what
they liked your outfit is were you
saying oh that's nice so you were out
there having a good time and checking
the game brother what's better than the
Patriots giant super bowl better ever
that's oh great well I play I play both
games a lot i also have been playing the
first 20 minutes of the Women's World
Cup every week did you know by the way
that most New Yorkers are either jets
and Mets or Giants and Yankees yeah no
that's like that's like if you don't
know that that's generally yeah the
combo it's why people say what's the
most popular sports team in Chicago it's
the bears because that's the only team
everyone agrees on
the Bears are huge no no the Bears own
the town I don't care if the Cubs win
the World Series it doesn't have the
same effect as if the Bears when really
don't ya only the balls like the Bulls
own they don't rate no they do rate and
the Blackhawks have become the most
popular team in the NHL however the
Bears of the most pop Chicago is all
about the Bears boom good night it's not
all about the cobs not all about the
balls Hawks doesn't matter bears can I
Chicago question yeah if the Cubs get
into the World Series yes when they do
in the next couple years this year will
like have a good shot they do literally
the median age is like 21 22 dry I'm
salable they could do it like in five
years even cargo the other what is it
north side White Sox outside that's
generally what it is what it really
comes down to is that there's a there's
a equal amount whether people believe
this or not of Cubs fans and Sox fans
what creates the illusion is the fact
that the Cubs plan Wrigley Field
therefore when tourists come they go to
Wrigley Field they're not going to go to
the piece of [ __ ] yes stadium on the
south side I've been to a cub game that
goes in extra innings many of them where
they stop serving the beer it's about
the same amount of people at a White Sox
game in extra innings so this whole
illusionary thing about the cup what it
is is the common fan the common man the
person that doesn't really give a [ __ ]
are more into the Cubs okay because it's
more of a mainstream yes right but in
terms of baseball fans it's pretty much
equal I think you know yeah but it would
be a really big deal of the Cubs won the
World Series whichever yeah but but yes
but but if the Bears win the Super Bowl
it would be a bigger yeah wow I didn't
know that yeah
I just I thought exactly Cubs need two
bears and then white sucks nope there's
bears bears bears and then everyone else
put together why no I'm telling you it's
a bit of bears town I mean the Bears are
horrible like they are it's a sad winter
in chicago it really is i don't care
what the bulls or the black hawk look
the Blackhawks won the championship and
now they're dealing with with the rapist
I I don't need I even I can't even I
specifically for bed Jerry because I
love Patrick Kane I specifically would
whenever he's on the ice I watched him I
can't take my eyes off he's amazing he's
amazing he's a great hockey player great
Idol is stupid who is it because even if
he didn't rape the young lady he went
out on the town with a nut bag that's
the other option the option is either he
did it or something's goofy yeah either
way has has good ain't you back to his
know by the way who brings strangers to
their house yeah no thank you well it's
good to know yeah you agree with me yeah
where the hell needs that you go back to
our houses his pictures of her and her
husband it's creepy know it's so sad
like it's just a big balla wrong so sad
and awful because you get attached to
these players male female where you get
attached to Bill Cosby now you oh no you
do I loved Bill Cosby no no I'm sayin
I'm saying it's like it's it's a the
cult of personality the it's all just
it's r it's wrong and it's sad it's sad
that's all it is it is that and I'm and
by the way you think in the 1700s there
wasn't crazy guys drugging women and
doing the things or someone is popular
raping somebody saying [ __ ] just when it
happens it's on a 24-hour news cycle you
know I just don't
no I don't want to know I do want to
know I want to know but like you say
something to you subway [ __ ] them here's
why they took some guy that all he did
was eat turkey sandwiches he lost weight
and they told us a follow him [ __ ] them
they deserve the [ __ ] they've done it's
all about quiznos you guys they eat
their sandwiches is a lot more variety
and they don't let their employees [ __ ]
underage women and the policies like
plastic stuff runs before you make of
sandwiches and no [ __ ] children
mission same i know by the way he didn't
just be clear I don't want to make it
horrible from he didn't [ __ ] really
little kids he [ __ ] teenage girls now
that's wildly inappropriate but there's
something extra disgusting about with a
young child job yeah you know 17 year
old I've seen them yeah but you have to
have some self control and some decorum
and you have to basically say that's
wildly inappropriate I am a man that is
a girl that's all how about week two of
the NFL you guys a lot a lot a lot of
stuff happened um yeah you don't have
been though hey is it [ __ ] idiot
anybody of a football team where your
star player lights off fireworks and
blows his hands up oh the joy and then
e1 let the giant see his hand all this
is a picture that came out this week no
he why do I want to look at that I don't
want to even hear about I can't talk
about it no oh god you're going out for
you why do i do you understand how much
i hate fireworks fireworks fireworks to
me are the toy of the mentally
challenged fireworks make no sense loud
noise color bright light hurt finger gun
it's just they're the dumbest things I
number my kids it was really cool I
didn't let my kids go near him you know
and stuffing that I really dig him but
what's cool is my kids in that had their
revenge because they love fireworks and
they're going to Kentucky to get them or
whatever we have firework barns and
Kentucky I know and they got him in
Wisconsin and Indiana yeah people blow
outside the Chicago area yes Chicago
they have the intelligent people and
then the outside of that you can buy
your fireworks but the point bang is
fireworks are stupid and this guy's an
idiot at no point did he say to himself
it's the same thing y'all go off with a
hooker tonight dig Warren well yeah the
big dog I'll bribe losers before he
lights his [ __ ] hand on fire he was
the only pass rusher we had you know
what it's like to rush a passer but one
of her fingers removed not as cuz you're
at five fingers no it's not as good
because those guys grip you know there's
the deep defensive holding this imposing
coming at you with my nub he's not
playing yet is he now he's in [ __ ]
nub surgery yeah knob surgery no needs
that but I mean really though fireworks
are just to me this stupid it's your
measure by the way all right any time I
met a new year's party or a fourth of
July party and there's someone I don't I
inherently don't like I guarantee it to
happen every time they're the ones who
go for the fireworks every time like who
is that like Santa my friend is throwing
who is that dude I can't stand him
they're like what's my friend Tommy Luna
and Tommy's the one who goes he gets the
fireworks one time I wife was pregnant
with our first child and the Tommy of
that party who I didn't like lit
fireworks and one of them flew by my
wife and so what I did was I was
horrible but it was my friend's party
and he defended Tommy or whatever I took
my friends cake and I put it underneath
this bed and they didn't find it yeah
like yeah so that night they didn't have
a cake and it was under his bed my
pregnant wife was almost burned
I have Tommy and assuming it's where we
can yeah Oh mommy is that though that's
like the perfect name it just reminds me
of Tommy Boy just like a big idiot like
Tommy Brady Hey Oh Tom Brown Trish who I
love dearly is Tom Brady Brady Patriots
fan oh is that your family how did that
happen when you're all grown Kentucky
digging the Patriots when they really
suck yeah all those years before Tom
Brady you strap yourself in eighty-five
super boy you're like man I love I love
Tony Eason yeah so years yes I've been I
another blood so years happened after
the Tony you know that that's what I'm
saying let so makes wine you know who
Randy do you know Randy but taha was
look at your digging all the way in
listen Tyson one more time Britney
Brogan very hard time big things in
Randy Fattah ha though Brady threw for
466 would you thoughts on Brady Quinn of
marriage my jam he's not your jam
Giselle is my jam he's I don't like a
pretty boy I ever heard the term I don't
like they my jam he's not how I could
like a dude he doesn't doesn't about him
as a dude he seems old re i hope uglier
in a room he's naked perfect body big
erection your husband's saying honey
please go ahead and you're not going to
what that's the weirdest center that
there's nothing women aren't like that
weren't like dudes are like the hold on
hold on and then Tom Brady pulls out a
million dollars oh look what's on Gladys
Knight in the back I assume that was
already parted right
and says a familiar Aaron Rodgers is
more my jam okay hold on hold on I'm
sorry Aaron Rodgers popsun yeah says if
you [ __ ] Tom for a good 20 minutes
i'll give you a little bit of a ride I
don't know how we got to there but um
yeah I think I just played it to Giselle
I'd like that alleges oh I'd tap out for
Giselle you tap out or would your Cap'n
brace yourself talking to cash yeah for
a million I cuz i clear i thought i'd
probably do for a couple grand get me
out of a couple jams listen my directv
bill is high listen Tom Brady Tom Brady
466 yards using illegal gloves I have to
fact-check every stop of the illegal
gloves he was not he was on a mission
and I love that Rex Ryan admitted he was
out coached I love it Rex Ryan did did
Rex Ryan is that like lap band surgery
yes it's exactly it really looks trimmer
and more awkward as a human and then
he's got his odd sweet little brother
walking around looking like he ate hey
man I don't get that right I like I like
a George the win with that freak you out
cuz they're identical twins Rex and his
brother if the defensive coordinate the
whole defensive coordinator of Dallas
yeah there that's his twin yes no let me
they don't look anything alike cuz he's
got his big old for hair and he's and
he's not hot lap man their family means
a lot to me no it does their dad buddy
ryan coach the best defense in the
history of the NFL yes buddy i'll give
you I actually like Rex I like Rex going
in and being like you know talking is
comedy sure appreciate that I think at
the same point you have to remember that
no one knows who your quarterback is in
court including the quarterback and and
also it's the bills but they needed that
they brought him in the mouth me yeah
that's why I let it was they were only
done by six with like 40 where it was a
little rough today uh you know what the
best stat of the whole week is tomorrow
Marie had two yards today two yards last
week no this week today 20 yards yeah he
had two yards against the cowboys that's
the greatest thing ever cuz I hate them
both
um all right let's make some pics you
ready drumroll week three NFL picks
starting Jeff Garlin and Trish Suhr now
these pics based on whatever doesn't
even matter no no not poor I'm in like
one of those things with points and I
suck no no just do you want all right
well I'll probably win okay keep track
for next let's keep the bull keep track
happened last week one season I was in a
office pool a spread pool in a fantasy
league and I shot myself but but my
question to you is though do you read
next week like what happened okay so
what happened last week my one because
Katie Massa my guess was picking on like
team names or something stupid she loves
tennis it was good it was great podcast
you like tennis uh washington redskins
play the New York Giants last team is at
home what's it like my mention is at
home washes down to New York I'm gonna
go with the Washington Redskins Giants
it's your first win Giants rebound go
one and two went on a safety
accidentally with 10 seconds left
Atlanta Falcons play the Dallas Cowboys
okay Falcons Falcons go 3 and 0 Trish
Duncan's Falcons Colts travel to
Tennessee Colts Colts rebound yeah
rebound they play tomorrow night rebound
from tomorrow night they're all hungover
Raiders Derek Carr wow he's coming of
age Raiders what Raiders up go into
Cleveland I go go now Cleveland I take
the Raiders take the Raiders pause for
one second I was flipping to the browns
game to see if Johnny Manziel completed
but the past sober he did and there was
an expose on dog biscuits that are given
out in Cleveland you have to buy them
made of baloney yeah that's a snack that
a vendor of ending makes a vendor vendor
I'm let's keep going Cincinnati Bengals
play the Baltimore Ravens Baltimore
Baltimore Baltimore Baltimore
jacksonville jaguars go into New England
well what could happen
nothing that the Patriots can wonder if
Jack select has a team plane okay here
we go um no orphans goes into carolina
carolina carolina Cam Newton's looking
cams on by that flip today heaven that
flip was heaven till it was awesome yeah
it was pretty weird he's a Panthers fan
out there good job I don't think I've
ever met a Panthers person fan life
Eagles go into the jets jets I'm picking
the Eagles what girl yeah that sounded
like Tampa Bay Buccaneers rapey got his
first one today gross goes into houston
houston TX Texas Tampa Bay when I go tan
today on that one uh since were you know
who I love more than possibly say JJ
Watt God he's precious I love him I know
I love him too he's a woman didn't buy
out all right let me just ask a quick
question you're naked you're at home
your husband says somebody's coming over
to visit and it's Tom Brady he's naked
with an erection and he says just think
of Judge do you do with that one of
these scenarios come to you Jeff because
I'm funny I wasn't funny I wouldn't get
any good scenarios oh good I want to be
best friends with JJ Watt and Ronda
Rousey Oh they'd be a cute couple Oh
they'd be a couple that could actually
start a fire with the friction between
their bodies as they made love well so
powerful did you imagine their child be
like what if they did if they had a they
could cause a fire on the house of they
just stared at each other San Diego oh
by the way Philip Rivers passes Dan
Fouts four touchdowns today remember Dan
Fouts yeah Jefferson not so much better
yeah uh Wes Chandler Minnesota Vikings
sandy hrc I Vikings I got Vikings who
are you playing san Diego's gone so he
was going to Minnesota I'll go of
Minnesota I'm gonna go
Sarah uh Steelers play st. Louis
Steelers Steelers Steelers san francisco
49ers travel to arizona arizona Niners
Niners Wow all right what's up with
Carolyn Colin Kaepernick I can't with
him he buys a buffalo Buffalo travels to
miami miami what is it like they always
have like oh it's gonna be the Miami's
gonna win that win though I go buffalo
don't Chicago Bears I'm afraid I like
this this is good go bears go to Seattle
oh that's easy Seattle yeah sorry uh
Denver Seattle gets their first win yeah
it's the first win against it we did see
a villista Green Bay already yeah yeah
the Green Bay has it well except for the
playoffs Denver Peyton turns 102 and he
goes into Detroit remember denver denver
kansas city chiefs play the Green Bay
Packers my bad Oh Packers nailing it
people nailing it um you guys we've
reached the end of the podcast Oh hail
quick a couple shoutouts WNBA Oh God
Trish I try to convince every week I
love I love women's basketball oh my
liberty and my sparks came back one
today Tina Charles 22 points in your
face Candace perfect what if I thought
you go to games yeah what is where this
is
I wear a real low cut tube top that
makes no sense do you ever heard you
ever wear a v-neck tube top in riding
boots nothing in between ah mark this is
embarrassing well it's the Emmys but the
sparks everyone's just like we got to
get more people involved in women's
basketball the sparks playing game to go
win or go home playoff against the
Minnesota Venus what does Amenas just
the Minnesota Janine and it's a better
name sparks you do remember out of get
kicked out of the staple center that's
where they play they can't play the
saber center because a bunch of
good-looking people are getting away
with anything at UNC that was her in a
statement oh yeah yeah oh no they're
across the street from the staple said
yeah it is a staple center this year
this year they're in the stairs always
in the staple know that idea they're the
Nokia across the way they renamed it my
way song what are you talking about the
enemies yes I'm sorry I thought you
talking about the sparks but but but
here's my gun it was like a party or see
I don't know about what I was gonna say
to you is there's no way you could have
an event at the staple center if they're
having the emmys of the nokia oh you
shut it down well you should look it up
on your phone yeah it's at Microsoft
what I'm saying is you're right they had
to play in long beach today jose
microsoft yeah okay though they had a
plane long beach she won depressing that
is no longer know what likes the
decorators stand-up comedy concert of
all time was filmed in Long Beach was
that Richard Pryor wanted live that was
at the long beach arena really yeah i
just watched I just flipped around and
saw Eddie Murphy brah I'll got that
outfit outfit a lot of choices by the
way he's wearing gloves can you imagine
if you went up in more gloves
here's the thing that you don't know
about me one Michael Jackson's bad came
out I only wanted to be bad so I wore
gloves but I didn't wear leather I wore
chiffon chiffon men's clothes chiffon
men's clothes and gloves and v-neck tube
top what if I just started working
wearing like tight gold lamay but like
what happened to foaling I would be I
wouldn't be hanging with you it'd be too
disturbing WNBA playoffs watch them it's
amazing women's basketball uh Carli
Lloyd hat-trick against Haiti I could
probably get a hat-trick against it he
put the point is she's amazing when I
cut a hattrick what those humans a
national soccer switch i switch to have
tricking basket lady [ __ ] here's a
pilgrim over the week we always end the
podcast with the feel-good moment the
week because everything's burning and
people hate each other and the feel-good
moment the week happened it's so good
it's so good
a fan gave me that selfish I've got a
Hall of artists by the way it happened
at Turner Field where Jeff and I went to
a braves game they play the cubs and
then we they came to our show Jeff show
opened oh no he found he found the
volume and remember remember Glendon
rush I called poppy my show all these
really writers yeah all these pictures
from the Cubs came to her a comedy show
and then i had a couple too many and I
called my friend poppy in New York who
helped me with the peaches this year and
glend it I made Glendon rush talk to
poppy and puppy's head fell off with
happiness are you guys such a good store
just for me that wasn't in the feel-good
story it's just in we've got y'all up
service and we may never get this
feel-good moment out of the week because
jeff has found the sound machine but
last week in Turner Field I it was a
kiss cam at the braves game ever get
more than every was given toward a
dollar to make out on the kiss cam and
the kiss between it was Jimmy Carter and
his wife Rosalynn Carter made the kiss
cam it was a sweetest kiss they've been
married 59 years 59 years that is the
shotgun new ones that's how they got
married
it was George our universe out gun one
oh my god I don't think anyone's ever
brutally brutally taken down the
feel-good moment of the week thanks Jeff
oh my god it was a really sweet kiss in
the middle of America's pastime is none
no there was no shotguns involved he's
one more I broke it it's not working uh
you guys force without balls fans
friends family that is our show you guys
thank you thank you to jab garland they
get a Trish Suhr thank you to the Los
Angeles podcast festival thank you for I
ball audible.com thank you for the dudes
in the back you're wonderful thank you
for plugging everything in and putting
the lights on you guys staple center
thank you guys so much for coming out
and we do too it every week so I just
keep listening thank you guys sports
with all balls fans have the best week
of your life hates Erin Foley hostess
sports without balls I wanted to give
you a little bit more information about
audible com cuz that website is pretty
amazing they have more than 180,000
audio programs from any genre you can
possibly imagine and it's super easy to
use there's free apps for any type of
phone you have you can download it to
any device you have and unlike streaming
or rental service with audible you own
your books I do a lot of traveling I use
audible com i just downloaded all the
light we cannot see by Anthony Doerr I'm
so excited to start listening to it
audible is offering our listeners a free
audiobook of your choice and a free
30-day trial membership just go to
audible com backslash LA pod fest and
choose from over a hundred and eighty
thousand audio programs you download a
title free and start listening it's that
easy go to audible.com slash LA pod fest
that's audible.com / la potf EST and get
started today I'm telling you it's
fantastic